vos enfants n'auront pas de cadeau de
fête des mères cette année
viens on fait un bébé [ __ ] c'est quoi
ce délire tu es enceinte mais non c'est
pas un test de grossesse à bâle
je réponds pas c'était appelé quatre
fois puis ce matin la corniche pas que
j'aurais été trop sensible curieux aussi
grâce à ma mère sa fille je pleure
l'écoutant puccini c'est grâce à ma mère
c'est son regard sur la ville qui m'a
construit
toi tu es supérieur parce que quoi parce
que tu t'es reproduites pourquoi vous
parlez pas je vais vous dire ce que j'ai
écrit
oh
on
maman
e
c'est pas le monde craque et de notre
histoire je suis pas la hauteur je le
sais qu'ils sont puissamment effet
pourrait parler
pourquoi j'aurais voulu être un père
soit le plus indulgent avec les pères
avec les armes en général des ja
sa vue comme tu serais ben importe quoi
vous avez des enfants vous non
je serai la mère parfaite avec l'enfant
que j'ai pas encore eu
est-ce que ça va être comme ça aussi
pour la tête des passerelles de la fête
des pères
on s'en fout
[Musique]